I think we should study religions and
see because they've had thousands of
years to hone their
to be you know to compete in the
difficult market they're now failing
completely and I think it's because of
the information revolution is that they
are all designed to work basically in in
murky water
where where where people couldn't see
outside and now they have to work in
translucent transparent water and it's
much much harder but they still have
there's a lot of design wisdom and how
they evolve over time and and but in
particular there's one thing that they
have done and they've done a very good
job of it compared with everything else
and that is sort of summed up in the
line from the Robert Frost poem home is
where when you have to go there they
have to take you in
there's no secular institutions of which
that's true and there are a lot of
people that don't have a home and if we
could create secular institutions that
had as their model no matter how
down-and-out you are no matter how
little you can contribute to the
pleasure of the group that's the Harvard
that's why book clubs you know no
illiterate are not welcome if if there
was some understanding some tradition of
a place where when you were really at
the absolutely and income inequality and
so the lack of the social safety net
absolutely it is very regular you know
some subgroups of various countries
would share cultures in common but
differ on these two dimensions they
always go together and of course the
reason why United's either less yes the
reason the United States is so much more
religious than the other countries of
Western Europe with whom we share a
culture is because we have the greatest
income inequality and the weakest social
safety there is something is Nick and I
talked about in the car ride over but
you know there is something one of the
parts of the religious experience is
dealing with what you would call with
various contentious words transcendent
sacred spiritual you know ineffable
parts we you know things that in our
contemporary vocabulary tend to go along
with supernatural beliefs but maybe
don't necessarily have to and then we
can argue about on the political level
what is the most clear word to use about
it but but we become as naturalist a
little bit afraid of using those words I
mean we would certainly get a little
nervous if someone said we're gonna
start talking in public schools about
anything transcendent at all right but
then but then I'm completely sympathetic
with the idea that that's part of why
you know just giving people health care
is not enough to give them full-time
work in Europe I mean the Europeans
don't have this spirituality to replace
religion they don't have book clubs I
mean any institution and yet they become
completely secular in the last 200 years
right but but they suffer with this
enemy that well I think I'm just saying
that I don't think I think the enemy
needs to be cured can't be cured in the
short term it needs to be cured long
term Isis I don't know restructuring
there are groups particularly in my
experience in New York which is you know
an unusual place it's not very
representative but there are all of
these science clubs
cropping up what's very interesting
there's you know there's lucid secret
science club there's a nerd night and
and what's interesting a lot of them
appeal to very young people that call it
brains and beer one of the interesting
aspects is that it's very social it's
not just walking into a theater seeing a
play and turning around and walking out
a lot of the success of all of those
isn't just okay here's a common theme
that people are coming together on an
intellectual topic about usually I mean
all of them that I know of our science
topics of different varieties so they're
finding a community of like-minded
people in which to explore ideas they're
feeling you know connected they're
feeling smarter they're feeling like
they're improving themselves but the
social aspect is crucial to their
success they get to hang out and drink
and talk and I think it's one of those
things that's just cropping up naturally
that you're describing when America
turned against drinking when when the
campaign against drinking and driving
here
North America ah I think it had a
profound effect on the nature of the way
people could form communities right this
is a this is a culture in which
generally speaking you can't unlike in
most of Europe walk to the neighborhood
pub right most people are driving
distance from everything and really
where they might socialize now you've
made it very very inconvenient I mean
you know bars went bars went went under
not in New York City when people right
not where where you had a European type
a form of urban organization in spatial
organization more like here at fighting
but in Kansas in Oklahoma and Alabama
and and rural Ontario and the bars just
went under they couldn't they couldn't
be sustained because people had to drive
to them and once you couldn't drink the
drive there was no effort so so and you
know there were small communities in
Ontario which in the 70s were quite
secular and by the nineties had seen a
resurgence of religion and also the
closure of their bars well I don't think
this is a coincidence right points and I
live in New York as well and I think
that that's why there is that congruence
I mean I go to some of these science
class by the way there is also enormous
number of philosophy meetups and clubs
in New York someone with you know my
colleagues tell me oh it's very
difficult to get philosophy polenta rest
in philosophy [ __ ] I get 1200 people
on my meetup group that meets once a
month and it's not the largest in New
York but people can do that partly
because of course the variety cultural
variety of Europe but also part because
there are constantly places where you
can gather we can meet and you can reach
easily and torrent versa so the
infrastructure is important when I was
in Knoxville Tennessee the hell I could
do that sort of stuff you know the the
ridiculous thing at some point was at
the local newspaper featured you know
seven interesting things to do every
night in in Knoxville and on Sunday
night the most interesting places to be
in
was my basement because I was hosting a
book club there was no way in hell that
would ever happen in Europe or in New
York City okay but in Knoxville
Tennessee that was it why people don't
have that sense that of intellectual
community people don't have can't they
have to drive everywhere you can't walk
anywhere there's no public
transportation in transport so so to
some extent is the making the
availability of these venues but also
it's a matter of the basic
infrastructure of society if you don't
and that's why Europe is largely a very
different place than most of the United
States
you